good morning millennials
happy monday hope everyone is having an
amazing kickoff to their week i know
that you're probably not though so
after disregard after the blessing that
was the short week last week
this monday hits harder than ever like
knowing what's ahead of us it's just
it's so difficult but but this week
with all the excitement going on it
makes for a
more interesting week no i've literally
never been more grateful for a monday in
my life because tomorrow's tuesday and
that's the day my book comes out even
though like
why didn't i release my book on a monday
i'm sure like it's like new music friday
new book tuesdays i think so too
i think i think um so we have such an
exciting week ahead of us we had
such a great weekend if i may just share
um you know some of my tidbits from the
weekend on friday night i hosted shabbat
at my apartment
um my first time hosting at the new
apartment i did a whole vlog for our
patreon on it and i just feel like the
vlog is very like
i tried to emanate some aina relax
vibes vibes and i feel like people have
really enjoyed it i just want to give
like a shout out to
every um vendor that helped me make it
wow it was a wedding
just park east kosher catering just
really made it
such a feasty vibe and sober miss a club
that sent me such cute decorum like
everyone was so impressed by
everything i had to offer and i couldn't
have done it with those two vendors no
like i
without without without yeah no i knew
you were like going like balls to the
wall but watching your vlog really made
me see like how personal you were taking
the whole experience
and it meant a lot to me because like i
was a guest and like you were doing all
this
like for me no and when i said like it's
a tough crowd i was talking about
you oh wow i feel like i'm so easy like
i will go to your house and i will
pretend i'm having a good time and also
go home and talk [ __ ] about it
right but like that's i know that about
you and like i didn't even want you to
have anything to do i just wanted it to
be
genuine no i mean i was literally like
cuddled up on the couch with michaela
and that's all you needed to arrange
like
the sober mesa and the couture months
like were nice but as long as i was
cuddled up with kayla
with miss k i was totally fine because i
haven't seen her since like the the new
year
yeah that's really tough but anyways i'm
so glad like that i had everyone and
great success i definitely want to do it
host it more often
i won't always go so extreme before the
first one i just wanted everyone to just
be
impressed with my hosting skills and and
i think that they that they were i think
so as well
um then my rest of my weekend was pretty
chill just home
watching downton abbey i started bling
empire
and i started your book oh my god so
just a lot of premium content lots of
new beginnings
and i closed a chapter i finished lost
oh yes
and i have something to say i hate to be
that person that like you know
shits on the ending of a show it's just
like those people who like still
complain about like the game of thrones
ending like get over it
but jesus christ like this was really
[ __ ] bad like
maybe the worst i've ever seen um
i'm not gonna spoil it are you ever
gonna watch lost is anyone in this room
ever gonna watch lost
she watched it okay so spoiler alert if
you're ever
to watch it maybe just pause for a
second because so you know the premise
of the show is a plane crash they are
lost
yeah and the whole you know arc of the
show is like get off the island and also
complete what you needed to complete
like you're on this island for a reason
like find your destiny and then get home
and there are just all these different
elements of the show like the
there are so many different like tribes
on the island and there's all these
supernatural elements
and there's all this history of the
island and everything you learned about
like the island and the people
like is irrelevant like literally they
were introducing new questions in the
final episodes
new characters and it's because none of
it mattered because literally they
didn't tell you how the show ended you
have to like
figure it out yourself so it's like the
show the show ends and there's like
all the people who you love who have
died or who are still alive from the
island they're in a church
and then they open these doors into a
bright light so it's like
okay it was heaven the only logical
explanation that i found out online
was that the isla everyone died in the
plane crash but the island was a form of
purgatory like to see like
were you good or were you bad and people
there were good people on the island bad
people and all the good ones ended up in
the church and they went to heaven
so once i figured that out i'm like oh
okay
then i'm reading like jj abrams and the
other creators have like
vehemently denied that everyone was dead
the whole time so it's like the only
logical explanation like you're saying
is wrong
and so i'm on a mission because um you
know madison brown who plays kirby
on um dynasty is a fan of the toast and
her and idm all the time and we were
talking about lost
and alan dale is in lost he plays
charles widmore and i'm like kirby when
you go to work tomorrow like
you have to talk to her to uh sanders
charles whitmore or
caleb cooper you have to talk to him and
like ask him like what's the meaning of
the finale and she was like sure like
she's gonna report back to me so
i'm investigating okay that's a good
plan that you have
i'm grateful for the show because
whatever it was like a nice thing to
watch with ben
and there were so many characters that
like i really and truly loved like josh
holloway who's the guy from
yellowstone sexiest man alive like he is
like he's on my tim riggins list like
same hair like i just i love that vibe
and so i got introduced to like some
good characters but overall like the
show was really subpar like
and i don't know why like like jj abrams
like never worked again it's like this
is his legacy i'm like well your
legacy's a piece of [ __ ] like
it's terrible like i'm just as a movie
critic tv critic i'm just saying like i
watch a lot of television and that's
like not a good show
okay decent premise but they were and
if they entered the show after like the
third or fourth season
i would say it was a really really good
show but like the last two seasons were
so disappointing that's always what
happens
they just disgrace themselves out of the
game yeah i know but it's like
show that's like shit's creek like [ __ ]
scree could have went on forever because
it was like a funny sitcom
but i respect even though i loved it and
wanted it to go on forever i respect
that they knew like
when to end it so it didn't become like
overdrawn and dan levy always says it's
like such a privilege to be able to end
your own show like most
shows get ended so i just feel like this
was like
i feel like they really should have like
protected the legacy of the show more
instead of like
flushing it down the toilet with jacob
and his [ __ ] twin brother like
so stupid i could die like okay okay
well i definitely won't be watching it
i'm glad you're done with it do you know
what you're gonna do next
um your husband who recommended lost to
me also recommended this new show on hbo
called crashing it's like about
comedians so maybe it's like
comedians watching other communities oh
i've walked in a few times while he's
been watching it i
i wouldn't consider it your vibe but you
never know you truly never know also do
you know a year ago today i was at the
beacon
wow my timehop was like really getting
me teared up on the way over here like
wow
timehop is about to really do that to
all of us yeah and it's just kind of
crazy that my book comes out one year
and a day after the beacon like
january 20s are like a good time for me
maybe i should have my second wedding
then oh my god for sure also second
wedding to ben's also your big
milestones are always right around
dina's birthday
and ben's sister's birthday literally
last year was the beacon
oh my god this year is the day after
that's so funny last year was
um like this year's book for dana but
anyways it's going to be a great week to
have a birthday to have a book come out
to have an anniversary of performing at
the beacon so so these exciting things
will carry us through the long
long weeks yeah i'm not feeling so
doomed by this week but i realize not
everyone is releasing a book today so no
but some
a lot of people a lot of people are
getting
this book that they pre-ordered and a
lot
a lot a lot like literally like okay i
was trying to find you up
no i'm humping myself up too like a lot
you can get it now at girljob.com book
and the good news is that if you
pre-order it now it'll literally be here
on amazon like tomorrow the next day
i actually just got a notification that
mine shipped wow that's exciting i know
it's getting really real it's getting
really real so tomorrow next time you
see us like it will be out you guys will
have started it if you have a kindle
or if your mail comes really early yeah
i don't know like the time
i still haven't figured out if kindle's
come out at midnight i'll let you know
yeah please do
actually i have your kindle i can let
you know yeah um we have an amazing show
for you guys today lots of things were
happening over the weekend yeah madison
teddy drama which it's been a while
since we've had so much
pettiness to deal with and i have to say
i've missed it me too and sometimes i
really prefer the petty celebrity drama
over the heavy celebrity drama a hundred
percent because there's so much to keep
up with the pettiness it's like on
instagram like i can't keep up with that
no hard feelings like
i and so there's just a lot to talk
about and
i i look forward to discussing it plus
we're going to recap real houses of
atlanta and i feel like i'm missing
something major that i did this weekend
oh also rupaul's drag race something
major that i watched or that i did i
just
i only got through like one episode of
downton abbey the whole weekend oh well
no offense downtown season three was
just not good
well we are um we could talk about you
know it was like a lot of football
yesterday
oh yes very exciting tom brady versus uh
jackson mahomes brother i placed a bet
with zach just for bragging rights about
who would win each game and i won
both oh i um i bet on
what were the teams the bucks versus the
chargers i voted for versus green bay i
voted for jordan rogers brother
i bet on him i bet on tom brady and then
of course i bet on travis kelsey against
the bills
travis kelsey yeah yeah no i actually
was over two because i was like you have
to root for a new york team and the
buffalo bills
follow me on instagram it wasn't about
rooting it was about just predicting the
future like you know you're a good
wedding
it wasn't personal and you know last
year we did predict that super bowl
100 accurately because it wasn't the san
francisco 49ers time
it was not their time it was however the
kansas city chiefs time
so let's talk it out let's talk it out
because i'm i'm torn
i'm torn too let me tell you why i just
feel like it's unfair if tampa wins
because like they're playing in their
own home but i'm also like they can't
lose because
it's so rare that the super bowl takes
place in a city where the team is also
and so you have the home court advantage
and that's like a once-in-a-lifetime
thing right and it's tom brady and tom
brady doesn't [ __ ] up once in a lifetime
things
but this mahomes fella let me tell you
he is something else
and he is a stand-up guy like him you
know he's at the height of his fame
ben told me he made like five he
literally his contract is the biggest
sports contract ever
500 million dollars and he like owns a
piece of like the other baseball team
they like gave him a chunk of the
company
um and like he could be you know out
philandering but like he's a pregnant
fiance like i just love that about him
so i don't know i'm torn between like
you know tom brady who's
arguably the most handsome man alive
would you say yeah and
the goat is what they call him i don't
like that phrase but
he's the most handsome man alive okay
and then
you know a young on like you know an
entrepreneur i was gonna say
entrepreneur but like you know it's this
young team and they're like they're
gonna be the next tom brady and gronk
and it's like do we bet on the future or
the past
oh that's a tough one i think that i
need to
i need to continue to think about it
before i place my ultimate bet
but before i let you know whose time it
is before i let you know whose time it
is but i just want to say like i think
it's going to be a really good game
i cannot wait for the commercials oh and
oh the weekend they'll be good
yeah no i don't even know if i'll be
watching super bowl honestly like i have
plans
you do yeah like i just i think i'm
gonna be busy
but the super bowl is always just such a
letdown like the watching and the food's
never wherever we go like i'm just
always hungry no i couldn't agree more
because
some for some reason like for the last
couple years like when we have super
bowl outings
like we're always like doing the most
like chicken fingers and pizza is where
it's at but like
i want pizza like why yeah i want pizza
for the super bowl i could not agree
more
um i need to think about it a little bit
more before i place my official but i i
think i will go
with tom brady though event ultimately i
don't know
because for the chiefs it would be two
years in a row that's crazy
right so then it's like they're really
establishing themselves as like the new
generation
i don't know it's tough i haven't
decided yet but before sunday
i will let you guys know whose time it
is yeah we will let you know
and then you can you know place your
bets accordingly i don't i don't bet for
any money or anything just because
i hate the feeling of having to pay up
when i lose so well you have to pay
before so you don't no but if i'm like
placing a bet with zach like i just hate
when he's like
i won i'd rather i'd rather even when i
win like not have to accept money just
to avoid that feeling
it's like an emotional bet yeah yeah i
feel like bragging rights yeah of course
um just last year was so obvious that it
like wasn't the 49ers time
it's not as obvious this year no it's
not because they really it's ev it's all
of their times and they've all had their
times
and it's like i know this is the premise
of like
you know the game of football but it's
like whoever plays better
may the best team went yeah like 100
right and it also comes down to like
you know sometimes you have an off day
and you can't take that
no and i was really um thinking about
that yesterday because it was so cold
where aaron rodgers team was
but none of aaron rodgers teams were
wearing under um undershirts because
like they live in wisconsin it's like
not a big deal but like
all the people from tampa were like
literally wearing thermals underneath
right but they still won so maybe they
should have just worn the thermals and
stopped to like pretend that they were
so big and bad
wow so you know i was
reading twitter just like see what
people were saying and i do think we
should um officially call in a wellness
check on nick viall
because he was like literally having a
breakdown on twitter i guess he's like a
huge
wisconsin fan and also peter krause's
peter krause was out the game in his
full ski gear
only to watch his team lose no i know
but like i'm sure it's still exciting
it's like first of all in a pandemic
maybe
go to a football game it's the biggest
one second biggest one of the year
i'm sorry like literally seeing those
stadiums full of people when like i
literally cannot get a [ __ ] like
burger at a restaurant
made me so angry i don't understand the
science behind it and i'm sure there's a
good reason
why you know ten thousand people can
gather in wisconsin and like i literally
cannot get
you know uh a diner at 12 a.m it's fine
but it was
really frustrating to see they were like
rubbing it in my face were they
i didn't see it so i i don't know how it
was games but like when i saw like
peter's krause's story i was happy for
him it was how i felt
happy for peter for sure but both games
had like
half full stadiums and it just made no
sense to me i mean half full
outside better than half empty no of
course yeah by the way how positive am i
um should we dive in yeah let's dive
right in good luck to everyone
in case we forgot to mention it again
and truly may the best team win
may the best team win without further
ado it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
uh-oh call an ambulance call an
ambulance
but not for me because i have a job to
do you guys
today's episode is brought to you by
liquid iv you all probably know liquid
iv for their popular hydration drink mix
my favorite
best when you have a little tequila the
night before their energy multiplier is
an absolute game changer and gives you
that extra little boost that we all need
20 20 was rough so it's time to clean
the slate and start 20 21 on the right
foot
one of their sticks is like drinking two
cups of coffee and it's an all-natural
alternative to processed energy drinks
for sustained energy boost throughout
the day because half of americans report
that they struggle with daily fatigue
half what are those other people liars
everyone struggles with fatigue
some signs can include decreased focus
lack of motivation poor mood
and general unhappiness but with the
liquid iv energy multiplier you can
upgrade your vibe and reach your
constant state of awesome
for me the energy multiplier is fabulous
because i don't drink coffee
and i do suffer from fatigue and crash
during the day so the energy multiplier
is fabulous
they have premium matcha and green
energy blend they taste delicious and
provide a long-lasting energy boost
throughout the day
they boost you it's the boost that you
would get from one to two cups of coffee
but without the crash
liquid iv is also on a mission to
positively change the world the company
has donated over 6 million servings
globally
in response to cobin 19 over 3 million
products are being donated to hospitals
first responders
food banks veterans and active us
military grab your energy liquid iv
in bulk nationwide at costco or you can
get twenty five percent off when you go
to liquidive dot com
and use the code toast at checkout
that's 25 percent off anything you order
when you use the promo code
toast at liquidive.com
start fueling your adventures today at
liquidive.com
promo code toast love it okay first
story
big drama that went down this weekend
started with kristen cavallari and jay
cutler
posting a photo on instagram on
kristin's page a picture of the two of
them
his page too okay she said the world is
full of users
10 years can't break that so i saw that
and i was like actually that's pretty
cute because there's been a lot of news
about like
he's dating this person she's with this
person and now he's dating her to get
back at her
and i saw the picture and i was like
they're just saying like
screw you to all the rumors like they
still probably see each other
often and have each other's backs yeah
it was it made it seem like they were
like
back together no oh that's exactly what
i thought
i thought it was like there's so much
talk in the news about them but it's
like they still have to co-parent their
kids they see each other often they
speak often
and even though they're not in love like
you can't break their family you can't
break that bond
okay for sure i got it the vibe like we
are back together oh i did not get that
all but madison lacroix got the vibe
that they were talking directly to her
they were the caption was
literally so when i when i think about
deeper like who's been in the news with
them what are they
saying yeah so but leading up to that
there was more there was more before
that
kristen cavallari went live on instagram
with austin kroll uh
yes before she posted and craig was
there too yeah and they were just like
being nasty about madison
when there were like rumors about jay
and madison like maybe hooking up
no but no i saw it as kristen
and austin hung out in nashville
and then madison and jay started talking
like
after after yeah not before that's what
i said
okay sorry i thought no i'm just saying
on the instagram live like they were
being
catty about madison okay and then that's
right after she posted that story um
because madison had went live after
they're live just being like i have
received it's like lola
and they were just like kind of i don't
know everyone is like turned on madison
but like
i don't think she's doing anything wrong
no i don't think she's doing anything
wrong either
she then took to instagram stories
yesterday to set the record straight
wherein she posted
screenshots of text messages with jay
cutler um where he sort of like accused
her of like
putting their relationship out in the
public and also i think she was posting
the screenshots to show that like he
came
to see her and like you know like that
just that he's interested in her and
that they text
and not that like she's like so thirsty
for him but it was a relationship like
mutual
yeah no like she interest she wasn't
making anything up right i think was
what she was trying
to prove to everyone she also posted a
picture of this
of a selfie of the two of them saying
too bad it didn't work out
i agree and i i still like i'm holding
out hope i think
first of all i think jay cutler is like
so hot and so rich
like i under it's like when we talk
about the sabrina carpenter olivia
rodrigo thing we're like you're fighting
over this like you know
kid who's like 90 pounds like i don't
see it jay cutler like i understand
fight to the death 100 like i understand
why people are fighting for him
and i i respect it it makes sense to me
yes
and so madison stood up for herself and
i think everyone's just like living for
the t and i understand why she felt the
need to do that but also at the same
time like
there's never a chance that madison and
jay are gonna end up together now right
because i also like her posting
screenshots of their text messages even
though there was nothing like crazy
in them it's just a very exposing thing
to do
yeah and i think that you probably did
that because once jay posted that photo
of him and kristen on her inst
on his instagram with the same exact
caption it was like they're trying to
make madison look crazy and it's so
disrespectful to madison after like i
think they
slept together because she covered one
little part of the message
in her instagram story she very
strategically placed
some text over a few words and it said
you shouldn't have
s blank with me like she covered the
rest of the word but
you shouldn't have slept with me oh
interesting 100 right
yeah i didn't pick up on that at the
time i did i'm like why are you covering
the words like what what is to be
i couldn't think of another adjective
that could possibly fit in there yeah
verb sorry burt
yeah so this just all went really
downhill very fast i know and it's like
i don't know i kind of was like shipping
kristen cavallari in austin
and shipping jay and madison like it
would have been hilarious
and i actually really think both couples
are so cute yeah i don't see kristen and
austin as much as jay and madison
i mean i'm living for j madison but now
it's over like
i know we have to this is why we can't
have nice things no this is why you
can't build like nice ships and set them
out to sally before
the ink is dry yeah but i just want to
go on record saying like i think jake
cutler's so hot like yeah and i feel
like
i mean i don't know how they've come
back from this but you know stranger
things have happened
yeah even though i feel like they're
they're the type of people if they can
like co-parent and be friends like
they're probably much more healthy like
as friends slash co-parents
than they are is like kristen and jay
yeah yeah
oh and then justin anderson who's like
literally chris and cavaliere's
mouthpiece like was going
off on his instagram stories like i
don't know if like he speaks on his own
behalf or like
he posts things that like kristen wants
him to post but he was like really
putting himself in the middle of it what
did he say
i don't remember he was just like i'm so
bothered like you're posting private
text messages
and he wasn't wrong um but he's like so
clearly on
christensen it just feels like a
situation to me where it's like everyone
should just be like communicating
privately offline you know this just got
so big and now we're all involved and
it's like it just didn't need to be this
way
yeah no and it's kind of it's just kind
of crazy and like low brow like for jay
cutler to be going through like this
messy
drama because like he's jay cutler you
know yeah but he is like a reality tv
star and so is
his so is kristin at the end of the day
no so now it's on brand for them
yeah and southern charm is like super
it's a premium ass reality show yeah and
it's very top of mind right now
and it's top of the news cycle also
madison then posted like how many views
her
instagram story crazy double the amount
of followers that she has 500 000 views
i'm sure it went up too
yeah because like everyone is like wait
what did she say right i'm sure people
are gonna go look now they're still up
yeah the by the way the receipts are
they're legit like they are
receiptful yeah well they're just proof
of the fact that these two did text and
hung out and that he was interested in
her at one point and that madison's not
a user for
like going along with a very handsome
successful guy who wanted to like hang
out with her
yeah no i don't see it the way when we
posted on our instagram like people were
like madison's so thirsty
i don't really see it no and also even
when asked about the situation like
uh like she was super coy about it like
i never thought that she was
thirsting out the situation like i
thought she was
acting completely fine agreed so i mean
what kristen
and jay posted like was definitely like
a strong message yeah no and they really
started it
yeah and she finished it that she did so
i just i would implore everyone to
you know think before you just go and
attack madison because i don't think
that's the answer here yeah i just don't
think she takes any [ __ ] from anybody
i think the answer here is that jay
starts seeing um that author claudia
ashrae
and then like the whole world wins you
know yeah yeah i'm
maybe no i think that's the solution
okay ready for our next
love match story is it the love match
story brought to you by love book online
yes how beautiful crazy valentine's day
is coming up and love book is everything
of the sort it is a personalized gift
that helps people express feelings that
might be difficult to say out loud
most customers use a love book to
revisit their fondest memories or to
list the reasons why they love someone
love books are completely customizable
and people can use them however they
like
users use the book to create characters
that look just like themselves and the
recipient
with all the features that make them
unique they can even choose their
favorite hairstyles and outfits
and while customers have the option to
personalize each page as much as they
like
with the express option you can create a
complete book in just a few minutes
this is such a sweet idea for anyone
who's just like really appreciates a
sentimental gift
and with valentine's day coming up with
your mom your grandma your lover
um love book is just an amazing gift and
it's so unique it's like everyone just
gets the same thing for valentine's day
like
a wallet you know yeah this is really
creative it's a perfect gift for any
occasion
but especially for anniversaries
birthdays and of course valentine's day
visit lovebookonline.comtoast to receive
a special 20
discount only for our listeners again
that's lovebookonline.com
toast love it well here's to love
bookers travis
barker and kourtney kardashian are
allegedly
dating yes yes yes the longtime friends
are dating page six has learned through
though the development is a recent one
both barker 45
and courtney 41 each shared similar
photos from kris jenner's palm springs
california vacation home over the
weekend
alerting eagle-eyed fans to the fact
that they were hanging out that house is
sick
so sick so this is like
probably true not confirmed though they
also are just long-time friends so like
maybe
they were having a friendly day maybe
there were other people there if they
are
you know dating we can speak
hypothetically like i think this is a
great match
i agree um because for a multitude of
reasons like i just i really like travis
barker especially some of the content he
makes with machine gun kelly and they're
really good friends and i'm thinking
that maybe like machine
megan travis and courtney like might all
hang out in the near future and the
possibility of that
excites me yeah and then maybe like
randall and lala
too and the possibility of that is truly
it's like spain it's
even more exciting i agree i think this
would be super cute but i'm i'm just
really
skeptical of the news i just feel like
whenever it comes to courtney
kardashian's dating life like
the media is always getting it wrong
like remember when they said she was
dating justin bieber
okay i do think there was some truth to
that i really do i i don't completely
disregard that
but i do think that kourtney kardashian
in her post scott dating life
has some of the worst taste in men like
while eunice was very good looking like
remember that video of him like beating
the [ __ ] out of someone like
yeah i just don't think she has good
like a radar for men
um but i actually think this might be a
decent match yeah i mean friendship is
really a great foundation for a
relationship so that's true the longer
you know someone
plus they both have kids his kids are a
few years older than hers
but you know it's always nice to be with
someone in the same season of life
100 so so this is great i mean
um i look forward to seeing some of the
content that comes out of this
relationship
and hopefully i could just see courtney
like you know getting into like rock and
like playing the drums you know
yeah for sure no i really could see it
yeah being like a rocker's girlfriend
yes i kind of love that for her me too
you know i felt for a while like
courtney doesn't know like what her
purpose is you know and i feel like it's
to be a rocker girlfriend
no that's like so demeaning i'm kidding
like it's obviously to run the
brand that is push 100 so successful
okay this next story is
just so strange um an imposter has been
posing as riverdale star lily reinhardt
in interviews i'm sorry this is
hysterical hysterical and it's like
this is such a weird story i'll explain
but it's also like a victimless crime
yeah well yeah an imposter successfully
posed as riverdale star lily reinhardt
in a magazine interview
um 17 magazine admitted they issued an
apology on friday saying it had briefly
published a story
with information believed to have come
from the actress they said
quote it was brought to our attention
that the person who contacted us was in
fact an impersonator and had no
connection to the riverdale star
we want to sincerely apologize to lily
and her fans for this unfortunate
situation
the magazine scrapped the article from
its site and said it would be internally
reviewing their editorial and
fact-checking process yeah i should
think so to ensure something like this
does not happen again
then lily addressed the weird situation
in her instagram story writing
for some bizarre reason someone
impersonated me in an interview with 17.
nothing inappropriate was said but those
were not my words and i wanted to
address it
um they also this impersonator also
duped um
of other publicists and reporters that
had to rescind articles as well
saying that they had some like
information about the new season of
riverdale but like i get i didn't read
the articles while they were up but
nothing crazy crazy was said it was just
something what's the point
get right like it's so weird well and i
guess it's like
obviously you know journalists should do
a little more well that's information
they're talking to you truly an
indication of the low level of reporting
journalists now abide by a hundred
persons like it shouldn't be
easy to trick like someone at seventy
like okay seventeen magazine is for
teeny boppers but it is a legit
institution owned by like contain ass
right like
it is a or hearst it is a full-fledged
like magazine
it this shouldn't be happening like this
is really embarrassing
yeah um but i just don't understand the
purpose like if you're not gonna like
say something insane to try and like
embarrass lily or like
what's the point of impersonating just
to prove that you could maybe just to
prove that you could
because it's like this is such a weird
story
no it's so bizarre yeah you're right
it's truly a victimless crime except
like
this has brought so much shame to the 17
magazine name
yeah because like would this happen
at you know the wall street journal i
don't know
fake lily never made it that far say she
knew she couldn't dupe them
fake lily like i just it's also is this
a crime like can you get arrested for
this are they gonna
investigate i don't know i don't know
i've never heard of anything like this
i don't think it's a victimless crime
because i don't think it's a crime
to impersonate is a crime no no that's
like
a talent it's fraud fraud yeah but
you're not like spending money
i don't know i just i don't know if like
if someone works in you know
law enforcement like is this a crime
yeah
it has to be something illegal you know
it kind of reminds me of that
uh i forget what the prank was i just
remember it was really strange
when they thought carol baskin was they
they tricked her into thinking
yeah that was crazy that was crazy so i
guess
it had been done i don't think charges
were pressed in that instance that's so
crazy
like hilarious yeah okay
next story a little more update on the
teeny bopper news of last week sabrina
carpenter
is breaking her silence about her new
song skin amid the joshua bass at olivia
rodrigo rumors
okay so all weekend everyone said what
they needed to say
about her song skin and i actually i've
so many people commented on our youtube
and on our posts like
um with their opinion on the situation
and most people agreed with you
and usually when i like see counter
arguments to what i'm thinking i'm like
oh well yes yes yes
and i don't know why just for some
reason i'm just like it's not that
serious like
i just really like sabrina i can imagine
what it's like to be on
you know her and just to open her
instagram and it's all this drama all
the time and like she's the
other woman villain and so given all of
that i just didn't think the song was
was mean like everyone else thought okay
but the general consensus and i think
the reason why she posted this instagram
caption was a response to the public
consensus of her song was that like she
went
like below the belt olivia rodrigo was
just writing a song about her feelings
and then sabrina goes and writes a diss
track like oh i'm [ __ ] your man yeah
that's what i was just about to pull up
this meme that's like olivia
i'm heartbroken you're with an older
girl serena
[ __ ] like it was just the general
consensus was that it was a lie it was
an overreaction yeah and like
the the consensus was that olivia's song
was not about sabrina there was a line
in it but it was really about the
heartbreak whereas sabrina's entire song
was like
ah [ __ ] yo [ __ ] olivia like it was just
so almost
like hurtful so then she posted this
instagram with the caption in response
to i think
her song not getting the message across
that she at home yes so this is what she
said she said thank you to everyone who
has listened to skin especially those
who have opened their minds to lyrically
what i was trying to get across i feel
like she's talking to me
literally you're the only one who
understands serena carpenter
i mean it's a hard spot to be in but
i'll do what i need to do i mean
would it be an episode of the morning
toast if you weren't having an unpopular
opinion no it would not be
okay she said i wasn't bothered by a few
lines in a magnificent song
magnificent magnificent song and wrote a
diss track about it i was at a tipping
point in my life for countless reasons
so i was inspired to do what i usually
do to cope write something that i wish i
could have told myself in the past
people can only get to you if you give
them the power to and a lot of people
are trying to get to me
that's what i'm saying like when she
said you can't get under my skin i don't
think she's talking directly to olivia i
think she's talking to like
everybody who's like you know her the
fans coming for her yeah well regardless
of her intentions it looks like she's
coming for olivia got it she said the
song isn't calling out one single person
some lines
address a specific situation while other
lines address plenty of other
experiences
i've had this past year well considering
it's a song about the past year it's
just weird timing
it also shows that many things have
actually gotten under my skin and i'm
still learning to not give other people
so much power over my feelings i know a
lot of you struggle with the same thing
i don't want this to become an endless
cycle so please take this as an
opportunity to send
don't take this as an opportunity to
send more hate anyone's way
um i have a few things to say the first
is that
um people found out on tick tock you
know when you i saw this when you put a
song on spotify on music
on your instagram stories like to add
music to it you can choose a setting
that has the lyrics roll through
and when someone was two people i saw
when they were putting the skin lyrics
on their instagram stories some i guess
like a different version of lyrics
showed up and it was like
you won't get it under mine
no it's like i won't let you get
undermine something something because
josh is mine
and two people saw that line show up um
one person saw so joshua is mine and
another person saw so josh's mind
so i just think it's like a little you
don't think it could have been edited
two different people i don't know how
you edit that it looked it was like a
screen recording
of a girl literally like showing i'll
post it on our
stories okay that that's weird but i'm
gonna just reserve
like i'm just gonna be a little
skeptical until people edit the craziest
things all the time
what i had seen was a um
a clip from her show girl me too yes i
saw that
uh her co-star rowan blanchard is
reading a poem and like
two of the lyrics from the poem are this
are also in this we could have been
friends in another life
yeah and you're a tall blonde girl or
something yeah it's like you're tall
blonde and we could have been friends in
another life which is like
those are just words and it's possible
for generic people to have the same
thought
it's funny it's funny and it's just a
coincidence yeah
um so i feel really good about where i'm
at in the saga which is just like
sabrina and olivia are both talented
queens like obviously olivia's song is
so amazing but i feel like sabrina's
like you know she made the most of the
moment
because so many people like were coming
for her and
i can live with that i just can't
believe she's still with this guy who's
caused so much trouble you know there's
a clear winner here and there are two
clear losers in terms of
you know the song i guess you could say
olivia's the loser because she lost the
guy but like i would much rather be
olivia right now with the number one
song in the world
and having like my ex and his new girl
like trying to ride my coattails and
like putting out songs that don't
even reach number one on itunes like
yeah so who's the real winner
olivia's definitely the clear winner but
i think like so many people are now
talking about sabrina carpenter and in
this business that she's in like
all press is good pressure 100 you know
yep i do know
and she'll always have me in her corner
and i and yeah and now she knows that
and that's who you really want in your
corner like
i i literally i was watching our episode
from friday when we were talking about
the sabrina carpenter thing
like i know that i'm right i really do
but like you were [ __ ] hard to argue
with like
you in another life like literally
should have grown up to be a lawyer or
like the head of the best debate team in
the world because you are just like such
a good fighter and
your point could not be better but it
will appear better because you're just a
better arguer
that's so interesting i should go back
to you oh my god oh my god i have to go
up against this [ __ ] like and that's
why i always just like
like defer to you because you're just
like right about but i think that we
there's two sides in this situation and
we represent both sides and so yeah
and someone watching is going to be
hearing what they want to hear but the
thing is like
my side is right but yours was better
argued
okay i'll have to go back and watch it
because it's like thank you for
just like making so many points i'm like
[ __ ] like you're wrong but like i just
don't know how to tell you
okay i mean only time will tell that's
true only time will tell
are you ready for time after time are
you ready for our fifth and final story
it's really disturbing
oh my god what food network pulls the
worst cooks in america season 20
uh season after the winner is charged
with a child's death
the food network has removed season 20
of worst cooks in america from streaming
online after its winner arielle robinson
and her husband were arrested for
alleged homicide
by child abuse in the death of their
three-year-old foster daughter
arielle a teacher from south carolina
was taken into custody last week in
connection with the death of victoria
rose smith
teacher her husband was also arrested
following the arrests the food network
removed the entire 20th season
of the long time culinary series from
the cables from the cable services
video on demand offerings as well as
from disney plus discovery plus
hulu and youtube according to deadline
that's the right move obviously
yeah um and good for them for like
getting out in front of it but
this story i mean it sounds like uh that
[ __ ] terrible documentary we watched
last year gabriel fernandez
oh i mean i don't know how you go from
like being on tv and
like a teacher to this yeah this is
just really like stomach like churning
churning yeah that's a terrible story
she died as a result of multiple blunt
force injuries
jesus so [ __ ] monster i hope you rot
in prison like a hundred percent
burning hell good on food network for
pulling it agreed
so those are the stories and i feel as
though you needed to know them we're
gonna recap real houses of atlanta which
like honestly
is really not good so far like yeah i'm
having such a hard time getting into it
and
who is drew like i just don't know her
at all it's crazy
yeah it's a tough season and i feel like
it's just another franchise season that
has been impacted by
the complications of filming with kovid
yeah um so our tv recap segment where we
will recap real houses of atlanta
is brought to you by fashion pass a
clothing rental service
that we uh love here at the morning
toast jackie i and margo have been using
it for quite some time
it's basically like revolve me to rent
the runway they have great brands like
for love and lemons free people show me
your muumuu
um so like all these great brands that
really are predominantly sold on revolve
but are
really expensive because they can spend
um they can cost over two hundred
dollars
per item like a sweater a dress or a
jacket and you're only gonna wear it
once cause you know
you're taking a picture and it's over
that um so they have a
couple different plans we're on the
trendsetter plan where you get three
pieces of clothing
and two accessories in every box and you
can switch out that box as many times as
you want
the shipping is super fast and they take
care of the dry cleaning for you so you
literally just send it back in the
pre-labeled bag they give you
and when you're done you get to choose
new items one of our favorite parts
about it is that if you love something
and you want to keep it you get huge
discounts
from fashion pass so it can be anywhere
from 30 to 60 percent off which is
fabulous you want to hear something
crazy i didn't even know we had a
fashion pass ad today
but these pants i rented them from
fashion pass and then i wound up keeping
them because i loved
them so what brand are they um i think
they're for la
uh i don't know i have to check but um
they might be for love and lemons but
what's crazy why i like them so much in
my love fashion past it's like i would
have never bought these pants right
for myself because i just would have
been kind of unsure about them i don't
know how they'll fit like the material
could be unflattering
but because of fashion pass like even if
they didn't look great on me it wouldn't
have to turn off yeah i would just have
sent them back
and i wound up loving them i never would
have bought them and i kept them and so
i bought them at a much reduced price
and i would have they're so it was a
win-win and you really have windows like
a lot
a lot i wear them a lot of different
ways and i just i absolutely love these
pants
um so shopping from fashion baths is a
great way to shop
because it's more affordable and super
sustainable um and we have a dis a
special discount code for you today and
it is the best deal that fashion pass
has ever offered
if you go to the fashionpass.com and use
the code toasta checkout
you'll get 50 off your first month so
you can try it for literally 29.
again that's the fashionpass.com promo
code toast to get 50
off your first month so you can try it
for just 29 i just broke my back trying
to see
what brand i'm so sorry i didn't find
out i'm sorry um
let's talk about real housewives of
atlanta so they're going on this trip
and i caught up um because last week we
were i forgot to watch but so i'm all
caught up now
and first of all this trip in south
carolina is a great idea
that house is so cute it really reminds
me of jackie goldschneider's west
hampton beach house
yeah that's like the vibe of the beach
house yeah oh that's a good point
um i don't know what you're saying
because all beach houses like can be
different but the
format the multiple bedrooms the long
boardwalk yeah
exactly yeah um and it just looks like a
really fun trip and like a unique trip i
feel like it's
never been done before well because they
had to go somewhere where they don't
have to fly
necessarily or let's talk about the
plane okay so
here is where i i was like ready to be a
kenya apologist
yeah but then she did herself no favors
when she told drew not to tell the other
women
not even that because i understand that
well first when she called her and told
her i was like that's kind of obnoxious
to like just
tell everyone what you're doing and she
never told them that it was because of
her baby
if she had told them like i'm flying
private because i'm bringing my baby
like that gives you like a legitimate
excuse
but she snuck her baby she snuck her
baby in she didn't even use the card
that she could have but then to come to
find out because if
some of the other women knew that they
would want to bring their babies like
made it not nice no i agree it was
really motivated
poorly motivated um because one it's
this is just like what happened in
potomac like wendy didn't know but that
was like a genuine miscommunication
wendy did not know that ashley was
bringing her child so
kenny went out of her way to make sure
nobody knew that she was bringing her
child
and it's worth mentioning that they
literally left atlanta at the same time
so kenya didn't go down early to check
on anyone she got there four hours
earlier because she took a 30 minute
flight while the rest of the women drove
for five hours like
if she had went a day before to get
herself set up that i would have
understood
but to literally leave the same day on a
plane you just wanted the plane and i
don't think she wanted to pay for a
bigger one i don't think production paid
for it like
yeah no i agree and she couldn't have
fit anyone else on the plane that she
did get
so i understand why like it is
what it is it's just kind of like shady
it's shitty as [ __ ] like yeah
and then it makes matters worse when
like the bus that they're going in like
is having all these problems like
they're so hot like
i was laughing and like that's just that
that would happen yeah and it's like if
she could only bring one person like why
is it
latoya i'm so bothered by latoya like
i just feel like she has like bad
motivations for being on the show
and honestly i think the fact that she
told kenya what marlowe said marla was
really giving her good
sound adventures that is what kenya and
she wasn't even talking [ __ ] she was
just like
being real yeah i thought that was not
cool
no i completely agree and i just [ __ ]
love marlo
um and you know who's really growing on
me is tanya like when she first started
being a friend of housewife
she was so annoying and i'm like who is
this smiley and nice and it just seems
so fake
and now after getting to know her like
that is 100 who she is and she's the
exact type of person
you want on a trip like this like she's
really fun i actually really like her
yeah but so this isn't cynthia's
official bachelorette party right
i don't know they were trying to like
they were setting it up so that maybe
this turns into cynthia's bachelorette
party and that's when the strippers come
oh maybe is that what like kenny is
planning
like no no no but like i think maybe
todd like i don't know if they ever take
an official bachelorette
party but maybe that's how this stripper
idea came to be in that conversation in
candy's bedroom well like this
the season has been like relatively
boring um but like the big scandal of
the season is what goes down on the
bachelorette party like apparently some
of the women
do something with the stripper right and
i'm just wondering if if that's what
this is
this trip i think it is yeah unless
there's another bachelorette party trip
no but they do go to i think it's
because i think that this is it okay um
also i think that uh in the last episode
that event that candy cares like
all these on all the house sides like so
many women are like i love charity i
love charity
but like candy really put in the work
like she put together an amazing event
and it was like exclusively for single
moms who were struggling during the
pandemic
and i just thought it was really really
cool of her um and i just
she's growing on me but i feel like i
couldn't put my finger on like why this
season has been weird and it's giving me
like a new jersey vibe
where it's like so many of the women
have just been on for so long that it's
just it stopped being interesting
right and also i was thinking about it
when like with the
two or the new cast members drew's the
only official new cast member
but since the women have been on for so
long and they're just like they're
institutions in themselves like
all the iconic lines and like we know so
much about them they have flourishing
businesses like
to bring on someone new that's like
just not an institution not an
institution i agree
it's really hard it makes them seem
small yeah it's
it's hard to like even get in there and
and i don't want to say compete but like
it these shows it's very competitive
it's competitive and so
i feel like they sh they need to
cast when they're casting a new
housewife like just someone who's
has more to give gravitas yeah i agree i
don't think that drew
is like a big personality um and i do
think when she invited all the women
over for dinner like it was so weird
like no one wanted to be there and they
all left so early it was like still
light out when they left
yeah i like felt bad for her i i yeah me
too they were it
it seemed like kind of fun and i thought
it was like cool how she was like
explaining her whole family and everyone
seemed really interested in like
the church and and i loved that she sang
and but that was it she was good
yeah she was when they did the flashback
to portia
singing amazing grace at the reunion it
really reminded me like
how the show used to be so much better
but like that was an iconic
moment that was so [ __ ] funny no it
was hysterical
um so hopefully it gets better like with
this drama like i think that the people
involved like
i think it's um portia and tanya i think
i don't remember
but i um i just love porsha like she is
literally
so funny and she is the backbone of this
franchise and like she deserves
whatever she's making double it i love
her
i'm excited for them to get there and
like maybe
oh it will one last thing i do think
it's like
kind of wild that um cindy is like
having a full-blown 200-person wedding
like yes it's outside but like it's just
crazy
yeah we'll see in october how it goes
down because what month are they in now
i don't know but they're saying like
atlanta's a hot spot and they're just
like
i'm like she's just like ignoring like
not ignoring because like everyone's
gonna be wearing masks but like i love
it's just like not a factor
yeah she's getting married 10 10 20.
right no matter whether there's a
pandemic or not
and that's i can appreciate that kind of
tenacity but it is really crazy
yeah um so that's the recap anything
else you want to talk about before we
wrap up today's show our final show
before i am an official
published author wow before your debut
novel do you have anything you want to
say
like before we'll only see you as an
author like
you know yeah um my book is available at
girlsnowjob.com
and i really i can't stress that enough
you know it's so important that you
remember that my book is available for
pre-order
i feel like anyone who listens to the
show like knows you know
like i literally want to do trivia where
can you buy girls on job
how many versions are available does the
audiobook come with the photos
no just the ebook and the hardcover like
literally a quiz i'm gonna quiz you
[ __ ]
you should do a quiz on your instagram
story like yeah like
i'm gonna choose the right answer like
oh my that's so funny but seriously my
book girls no job comes out
tomorrow you guys it is available
everywhere
you get books in the bookstores amazon
barnes and noble all the places if you
buy the hardcover and the um
e-books so like kindle digital version
there is
20 photos on the inside that have
pictures of my family pictures of
moments in my career that i reference in
the book
it's 240 pages it is a light fun beach
read if you've lived near a beach
and if you're not it's a nice concrete
read if you live in an apartment in new
york
um but it's really just my life's work
and it's really exciting that it's
coming out
um i'm going to be on good morning
america tomorrow so make sure you tune
in to that
what time i want to say 8 45.
something like that okay um but you can
just keep up with me on my instagram
and yeah just jackie oh has a blurb on
the back theo is the star of the back
cover
there's just so much to give and
honestly if you buy the book and you
don't want to read it that's fine it's a
fabulous coffee table book
it's quite tall and it's shaded and
it'll spruce up your bookshelf you know
and i do actually do want to show you
that when you take the sleeve off
this is like a sickening oh that's
sickening look like just gorgeous
if you're not into like you know
gorgeous
if you're not into models this is more
um
laid back for sure growth on our job.com
book thank you guys okay that's all she
wrote now thank you guys for
[ __ ] sorry thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know
every monday through friday on youtube
so if you're watching us on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
got rid of cat's box all the places
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
the morning toast and leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are
we hope you have an amazing monday try
not to let the monday blues get you down
and we'll see you tomorrow for
book day
you